[Música]
en mi día a día mi trabajo es seguir del
paso a las últimas tecnologías luego
sobre computación en la nube sobre
impresión 3d sobre realidad aumentada
realidad virtual tecnologías
exponenciales de manera general y creo
que tienen un potencial increíble
realmente para cambiar la humanidad sin
embargo hay otra parte de mi trabajo que
es quizás aún más emocionante que es
compartir sobre estas tecnologías a
estudiantes ejecutivos de todo el
continente y es curiosísimo como uno se
da cuenta que ni siquiera sin hablar de
las tecnologías más de punta sino las
energías más básicas el supuesto que
nosotros comprendemos cómo utilizarlas
usualmente es falso y esto aplica
particularmente a generaciones jóvenes
mil años que un día nacieron con el chip
nos damos cuenta que realmente le temen
a la tecnología creo yo que la llave
para perderse temores es comenzar a
conocer la tecnología y aprender sobre
ella y les quiero contar dos ejemplos
dos casos donde esto ha sido demostrado
el primero es en san lucas de tolimán y
ustedes se preguntarán cómo es posible
que haya una historia de tecnología en
este pueblo a las orillas del agua
atitlán en guatemala
en este pueblo de escasos recursos poco
a poco hemos metido iniciativas de salud
en particular donde vamos monitoreando
el registro histórico de los niños para
ver si están bien nutridos y están
creciendo bien si están bien de peso y
demás pero así es como llevamos nosotros
nuestros registros en papel comentó la
empresa el papel contrae lleva consigo
problemas se nos pierden los registros
de nuevos registros que no son precisos
no podemos tener un análisis estadístico
de los datos porque no existen esos
datos este problema llegó a oídos de
ingenieros en de la universidad stanford
quienes desarrollaron una aplicación una
tableta lindísima para poder llevar
todos estos registros de manera digital
pero hay un problema los indígenas de
estas zonas nunca han visto una tableta
no saben que es una tableta han visto
aparatos con botones por esta idea de
que hay un aparato que uno puede tocar y
con el dedo tan siquiera mover las cosas
era totalmente nuevo el primer paso fue
deciros mira hay una tecnología como la
tableta que existe y lo hicimos mediante
juegos de una manera amigable lo primero
era conocer que la tecnología existe
pero esto no es suficiente lo siguiente
es comprender que hay valor en la
tecnología y nos apoyamos en líderes
local
realmente convencerlos que había mucho
valor en aprovechar la tecnología para
llevar registros históricos y hacías
análisis estadísticos enfocar mejor los
recursos en términos de salud todo esto
yo hacer ganancia ya los habíamos
introducido la tecnología los
convencimos que haya valor el siguiente
paso era aprender a utilizar de aquí no
había de otra había que aprender a
utilizar la tecnología esta foto me
encanta porque una señora tratando de
replicar lo que haya tradicionalmente
venía haciendo en papel ahora en una
tableta poco a poco el proyecto ha ido
surgiendo y ahora lo que tenemos es un
excelente registro histórico a la salud
de muchos niños felices y contentos y
usted dirán bueno pero esto sucede allá
en un pueblo rural déjeme traernos a dar
un caso un poco más cercano a los que
están aquí en esta audiencia un contexto
empresarial vámonos a servicios de
infraestructura en la nube que son
servicios de computación de
infraestructura en la nube es el acceso
a una infinidad de recursos
computacionales disponibles allá afuera
que básicamente nos dan el potencial de
consumir capacidad computacional de
manera infinita e ilimitada y además en
el riesgo financiero y tradicionalmente
asociado con inversiones en tecnología
porque en lugar de invertir en los
activos
las empresas pagamos conforme vayamos
consumiendo entonces esto si esta
iniciativa crece pues compramos más si
nuestra iniciativa fracasa cerramos la
llave de agua y dejamos de pagar por lo
que estamos consumiendo realmente una
maravilla y este potencial de innovación
de la nube es realmente lo que me llegó
a mí a dedicar todos mis estudios
doctorales a estudiar sobre esta
tecnología como parte mis estudios
estuve trabajando con un proveedor de
servicio de servicios de infraestructura
en la nube y analizando el
comportamiento de los clientes en
particular conforme comenzaban a
utilizar el servicio nos damos cuenta
que la mayor parte de los clientes que
iban a abandonar el servicio que van a
salir corriendo se iban en los primeros
15 días era en estos primeros 15 días
que los clientes que no ahí salían
corriendo porque porque se confrontaban
una tecnología que no conocían desde
antes y es que aunque administrar
servidores en infraestructura como y
silvestre no es para nada trivial en la
nube las cosas son un tanto distintas si
se quiere al menos suficientemente
distintas como para asustar a las
empresas y que decidan dejar de intentar
utilizar este servicio que hicimos
entonces hacer algo al respecto quisimos
hacer un experimento tradicionalmente
cuando un cliente comienza a utilizar
se le llama me llamo para validar los
datos de tarjetas de tu tarjeta de
crédito que pases un buen día porque tal
si hiciéramos algo más además de esto
qué tal si luego validar los datos de la
tarjeta de crédito nosotros dijéramos
mira te quiero explicar cómo es que vos
levantadas un servidor en la nube como
escribo lo bajas como es clase es un
respaldo cómo es que monitorear el
desempeño y tu servidor cómo es que va a
funcionar tu facturación donde es que
está la base de conocimiento a la cual
puedes acudir en caso de requerir ayuda
nada realmente es sofisticado pero si
muchas cosas que estas empresas no
conocían cuando iban a comenzar o que
les al servicio era una especie de
arranque de ayuda para arrancar nada
particularmente sofisticado nuevamente
pero lo suficiente para quitarles el
susto inicial cuál fue el resultado
el esperado logramos disminuir de manera
muy significativa la problema que un
cliente saliera corriendo nuestros
primeros 15 días de hecho la
conversación con el cliente se extendía
a los sprint iniciales 23 minutos para
leer la tarjeta de crédito a 15 o 20
minutos lo cual era un costo para el
proveedor por este costo calculamos que
tenía un retornos una inversión del 58
por ciento estos veinte minutos que
invertimos en educar a la gente para que
le perdiera el miedo a la tecnología
realmente valía la pena ahora ustedes
todos sabrán que no es sólo comenzar a
utilizar la tecnología sino una vez que
lo estoy usando quien me acompaña
decidimos hacer otro experimento ahora
conforme los clientes continuaron
utilizando el servicio
tradicionalmente el proveedor ofrecieron
soporte muy básico a sus clientes
básicamente es el servidor están dando
el cliente está tranquilo y solo es el
servidor seca y entonces el cliente
tenía la potestad de llamar al perdedor
para quejarse y ver que estaba pasando
un soporte técnico muy asociado a temas
de calidad de servicio porque tal si el
perdedor hiciera un poquito más por son
las empresas clientes y en particular
qué pasaría si el perdedor se preocupa
por entender las necesidades
idiosincráticas de los clientes y
entrenarlos educar
y decirles mira me parece que una
arquitectura tecnológica de esta forma
te funcionaría mejor de acuerdo a tus
necesidades
obtuvimos los resultados bien
interesantes el primero es que los
clientes de los cuales comenzamos a
educar no sólo consumían más del
servicio sino que en el tiempo el ritmo
de crecimiento su consumo iba haciendo
más acelerado posiblemente iba
desplegando más aplicaciones en la nube
porque le tenían más confianza de nuevo
entendía mejor cómo utilizar la
tecnología tenemos otra métrica que
también medía que tan eficientemente
estaba utilizando el cliente la
tecnología otra forma de decirlo es que
también estás utilizando vos la
complejidad de la nube y notamos que
iban de la mano los mismos clientes que
estaban consumiendo más lo estaban
haciendo porque estaban utilizando el
servicio de mejor manera
y estoy seguro que ustedes estarán
preguntando qué tiene que ver esto con
nosotros y es que recapitulemos que
hemos aprendido aprendimos que el primer
paso para conocer una tecnología es
saber que existe lo siguiente es
reconocer que tiene algún valor para
nosotros una vez que perdemos el miedo
para arrancar su uso lo siguiente es
continuar aprendiendo sobre ella y es
que muchos de los que están aquí en el
aula y muchas de las personas con las
que yo te me ha tocado hablar con la
tecnología suelen dejar los problemas de
tecnología a los de tecnología a los
ingenieros porque les pregunto yo a no
profesores que lo mío es finanzas lo mío
no es tecnología
y cuando les pregunto y qué vas a hacer
en finanzas me dicen bueno yo voy a
hacer análisis de riesgo y crediticio y
cómo hacer este análisis inmediatamente
su problema análisis de datos se vuelve
un problema de tecnología en un tema
financiero una historia similar me en
cuéntanos de mercadeo que quieren
diseñar campañas publicitarias
inmediatamente me comienzan a hablar
sobre srm ciertas tecnologías una vez
más se dan cuenta que me están hablando
de un problema de tecnología en general
muchos dicen profesión o me metí porque
tecnología no es lo mío y pasado me
dicen yo no me matriculé en su curso
porque yo no sé de nada tecnología y
ellos creen que son especiales porque no
saben nada tecnología lo que no saben es
que el 90% los estudiantes viene a mí me
dicen exactamente lo mismo profesor por
favor
llévela tranquilo conmigo en su curso
porque yo no sé de nada tecnología y es
que ahí es donde está el primer paso que
no estamos dando ahí es donde está el
temor inicial que yo quiero invitarles a
votar porque algo que yo le digo mucho
mis estudiantes es que ignorancia no es
lo mismo que estupidez yo creo que puedo
ser supuesto que el promedio de la gente
en este salón y que nos escucha no es
estúpida por hay muchas cosas que no
somos ignorantes y muchas veces es por
pura ignorancia porque nadie nos ha
contado antes un cuento sobre tecnología
en el caso eso nunca tutor imán nadie
nos había presentado que tal cosa como
una tableta existía en el carlos en el
caso de las empresas nadie nos había
contado cuál es el potencial y el valor
económico de la computación en la nube
por ejemplo si nosotros tan siquiera
tuviésemos la motivación de ir y buscar
y dar ese primer paso reconocer que el
tema ignorancia es curable puesto que yo
soy inteligente después de esto puedo
aprender entonces sí vamos a poder a
comenzar a realizar el gran potencial
que tiene la tecnología pero comienza
por nosotros si no lo hacemos nosotros y
sólo dejamos a los ingenieros los
ingenieros sólo de computadoras saben no
entienden cómo funciona el resto del
mundo al menos la mayor parte los
ingenieros y yo soy uno así que yo sufrí
esas penurias pues recuerden yo fue
ignorante alguna vez también yo enseño
sobre tecnología pero antes de enseñar
tuve que aprender desde el gusto de
animarme a aprender sobre tecnología
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]